[Music]
for over six decades
sir david attenborough has brought the
wonders of the natural world to
television screens around the world
[Music]
but his new film a life on our planet
moves beyond wonder
to deliver an urgent message about
humankind's damaging impact on earth
and ways in which he's been adapting his
own habits for the benefit of the
environment
so david you're 93 you've
entertained us informed us educated and
motivated for
many decades in your television work
aren't you tempted to hang up your boots
at some point you said that
you'd had your share of the platform
meaning
television well what has brought you
back to center stage
what else do i do sit in the corner and
grumble
i don't think that i i like the natural
world
i live in london uh or west london
and uh i don't see enough of the natural
world
i spend my life going to interesting
places and looking at interesting plants
and animals
and if i can exploit
invitations that come my way to enable
me to go and look at interesting things
i go and the film begins starkly in
perhaps the strangest wilderness that
you visited
chernobyl where in 1986 the nuclear
reactor exploited terrible
accident and the immediate evacuation of
the entire city and the area
around it meant that it has stood empty
ever since
why choose that was a man-made disaster
was that part of your thinking
because a man-made disaster is what
faces us and what we are having to deal
with
and it was emblematic of the problems
that we have imposed upon the world and
of the necessity for us to do something
about it
but chernobyl just to flesh that out a
bit general was a particular
kind of nuclear accident
thankfully relatively few of those in
the world and certainly not on that
scale
you're talking about a different kind of
risk i think
mainly mainly in the time scale
what was the point about chernobyl is
that it happened bang like that
and and had to be it was a catastrophe
what we're looking at
now with any degree of historical
imagination
is a long protracted bang that is going
on
over decades it started 100 years ago
200 years ago
and we are now hearing the full uh
effects
of that explosion in climate change and
climate change and what's more
it's going on and we don't know where
it's ending one of the sort of
interesting things about the way the
debate has changed was that
sense that your films have engendered of
a wonder
that we would consider at home as you
say look at the aardvark or
the rare species of of bird and think
gosh isn't nature
marvelous in all its forms well some
environmentalists notably george monbio
here in the uk
have criticized you for focusing too
long on that
element of wonder which i think he
suspects is a rather passive response
and being sort of late on to climate
change and
the major challenges what's your
response yes well we are condensing time
quite a lot in in in that question uh
and
and my i was sent out by the bbc to make
pictures of the natural world um and it
wasn't widely seen in the fifties as
being
uh a crisis that we were failing by any
manner of means
uh and it was only far far-sighted
naturalist
uh like peter scott who who saw the
impending dangers
and when did you first feel the
impending dangers or witnesses
and the i suppose the the the first
first one that i really saw myself
personally um as being a a
sign of things to come uh was
back in the late 50s 60s
when the first time i saw a bleach coral
reef
and i realized that the richest
environment the richest ecosystem the
world has ever seen
was suddenly being wiped out and and we
were doing it
let's talk about the tone and the tone
of the film that you've
made now and how one judges it
and walking the line between wonder and
warning if you like
and i think that this film is rather
different the tone feels like a
departure from
things that you've done before you said
you don't want to be proselytizing or
alarmist
so how do you find the right tone that
makes people
alert perhaps perhaps feel a bit anxious
when they're watching
something but at the same time makes
them still want to watch
not turn away well um you can
can say which i think is true that
people won't care about things that they
don't know about and
have never seen and that your first job
is to make
uh clear what a wonderful world the
natural world is
and you can't expect people to to spend
money
or time or worry warrior concern or
political action
about an issue which about which they
really know nothing
so one comes before the other uh it's
quite true that you've got to decide
when you stop one and move to the other
but um but you've got to do both
what would you say to the notion that
this kind of work preaches to the choir
it's very engaged in by those who are
already concerned about
climate change or keen to educate
themselves
further but how would you convince
someone who really needs convincing and
has immense power but is perhaps
more skeptical or more limited in the
reaction that they feel is appropriate
i'm thinking of someone like
president trump for instance how would
you go about convincing him of your case
i i cannot imagine that i would have any
effect
at all on president trump president
trump's views have been
firm and clear and and well-stated
for a long long time and he's not going
to shift them
uh i don't think he's susceptible to
rational argument
so you don't think because obviously
you're interested in things like the
paris accords
the big level multilateral
government to government and broader
agenda
are you giving up a little too easily um
i'm not giving in because i'm not i'm
going on saying what i'm saying and
doing
the best of what i'm doing to the best
of my ability
but the brick walls and and heads come
to mind
uh and uh i see no point in going on
and on and on on this particular issue
uh working on the basis that the united
states of america as a democracy i would
prefer to talk to the voters and
who are whose minds i hope are still
open and available to logical thought
i mean has it worked so david have these
films really
worked to move public opinion
well all i can say is that things
changed and changed radically
uh in the 1950s i think perhaps
people who appeared on television
holding woolly monkeys and things
people thought oh they're like
entertaining and amusing and so on
but i didn't think they were
particularly important
and that has changed radically
and it's difficult to know when it
started i would say perhaps about 10
years ago
perhaps not more than that not much more
than that anyway that
natural history programs after all
natural history programmes for example
they were not shown on television in
many countries
america's idea of natural history
program was big game
and you couldn't persuade a network to
do a program about a wood wasp
you know not for the life of you
now that has changed and changed
worldwide
and and people are now very well
informed about the natural world
um and i'm i'm i'm delighted that that
should be so
people are more informed about the
natural world but what about their
changes in behavior
behavior very far from everyone who
watches will think of going vegan
stopping flying or
divesting from fossil fuels perhaps in
their
pension portfolio and indeed i mean
which of those which of those options
do you act on most personally yes i i
i haven't eaten red meat for several
years
and i as a biologist i i never had any
objection to eating
red meat i decided that my digestion and
my teeth suggested i'm an omnivore and
so
if there's a biological logic uh or
morality
uh it was okay for me to eat meat and
like a lion each
antenope um but i don't feel that now um
and i i just
don't want to eat meat anymore do you
fly less
um yes i suppose i do um
but i i don't i don't fly anyway
for fun uh i i fly as part of my
job i've been very lucky to see
more than the world that i can possibly
have imagined i would ever do
so i've had my fair share of that of
going out and looking at things
but so if i'm if i get on a plane these
days it's because
i think it's worthwhile not because i
think it's fun but because i think it's
worthwhile
the last couple of years i've seen uh
unignorable new wave
of environmentalism and protest
movements linked to it
all around us sometimes in the streets
extinction rebellion
from extinction rebellion to school
climate strikers um
obviously motivated by greta thornberg
and her example
which of these movements do you feel
most affinity with and any risks to them
um i think there's a risk about
disobeying the law
in the end you are we are all dependent
on the law
and we have to to to follow it
i can see that if you're a young person
you get very impatient
the the rest of the of the population
don't see things as you are
but i think sticking to the law is
rather important because in the time
we're going to come
when you've actually changed the law and
you then have to actually will say oh
well
uh now we've got the law changed you've
got to do this
well there's a there's a disjunction and
greta dernberg
blessing to the cause question
guttershamburgers has done
marvels and wonders and i think it's
absolutely astonishing what she's done
and she's caused the most mighty
potentates in the world
to take breath and suddenly think about
things
i have to ask you the last question uh
whether you are ever thinking of hanging
up your boots and i suspect the answer
might be not i think you you told me
before we got started someone came came
around to your house not long ago asking
if
if you were still around you're actually
planning to go back out
on the road filming again they did last
night at 10 o'clock
tell us tap on the door and my daughter
who lives in the same house as i do
went to answer the door and there was a
jab from a newspaper respectable
broadsheet which i won't mention
by name who said is it true that david
ambrose did
and she said not as far as i know
it wasn't he wasn't five minutes ago
so david attenborough thank you very
much for joining us
still very much alive you can listen to
the full
interview in our podcast the economist
asks
every week we talk to a high profile
figure click the link opposite
to find this episode and thanks for
watching